[Music]
hey friends one question that i often
get is how do you fly in a plane with a
guitar uh people think maybe you can't
do it think if you do it it's cost
prohibitive or your guitar is going to
get broken
well
i've flown on planes with lots of
different instruments and in fact this
last weekend i flew to play a friend's
wedding and i documented the experience
so in this video i'm going to share my
experience and give you my tips for how
to safely fly with a guitar
so the first thing i want to say is that
this video actually applies to all
instruments that are guitar-like in size
or smaller the other quick thing to
mention is that these tips might apply
differently depending on where you live
i fly mostly in the u.s and so i'm
familiar with many airlines here but
i've also flown in other countries today
i'm going to speak mostly about american
airlines but regardless i think you'll
find these tips useful so i'm going to
start by sharing my story of how i flew
this last weekend with my guitar so i
was flying with alaska airlines for the
first time and since i wasn't familiar
with them the first thing i did is i
went to their website and i looked at
their instrument protocol every airline
is going to have a portion of the
website where they explain what their
policy is for how to deal with musical
instruments in my experience in the us
most airlines have a pretty similar
policy and basically what that policy
says is that you can indeed put a
musical instrument in the overhead
compartments with most airlines
as long as there is room for the
instrument and you might think no no
they're very specific on the
measurements that has to fit in the size
of a carry-on bag but actually all the
airlines that i've flown with in the us
say the same thing is that for musical
instruments like guitars um those
measurements don't apply so actually as
long as the instrument is about the size
of a guitar or less you can put it in
the overhead and you'll be fine
unfortunately even flight attendants on
an airplane might not know their own
policy and you might be turned away at
the gate or maybe you have a flight
attendant in a bad mood so i recommend
printing out or having on your phone uh
their policy and you can even show them
and that should get you through if you
run into a problem so i show up at the
airport i have my guitar ready you put
it through security like normal so my
guitar got through security just fine no
one even opened it up there were no
questions about it the next step is
getting to your gates and figuring out
how you're gonna get the guitar on the
plane if you get on the plane late if
you buy a ticket and you're in group
five or six and you're the last one on
the plane your instrument probably won't
fit and then they're going to gate check
it personally what i've learned from
experience is that i like to show up a
bit early and make friends with the
person at the gate often they're very
stressed but if you're there before
people start piling up around them you
can say hi i'm a musician i have a
really nice guitar with me
and i would like to pre-board
to make sure that my instrument goes in
the overhead and i read that your policy
says i can carry on a musical instrument
as long as there's space so i would love
to pre-board that would really help me
out and although airlines don't tell you
this and often they make you pay for
this sometimes i've just paid i've
learned through experience that you can
almost always ask can i please pre-board
with a smile and every time that i've
ever asked they said yes so at this
point you'll board and you'll get
through no problem walk down the whole
you know runway all the way to the plane
but now you have the big challenge and
probably the most stressful part of the
whole experience you have to actually
put your guitar now somewhere that's
going to be safe and you have two
options at this point the first and
normally the best option is to make
friends with the people when you walk on
the plane and kindly ask to put your
guitar in the closet which is usually
right where you enter on the plane so
when i did that
they said sure of course and they seemed
a bit surprised i think maybe no one's
ever asked them that question before so
they moved their personal belongings a
little bit and they they let me put the
guitar right in there and they actually
they were super nice about it at the end
of the flight they even got it out in
advance and they were waiting for me to
hand me my guitar so they were super
polite so if you get on the plane and
even if the overhead is full you can
always ask about the closet the second
option is to simply walk on the plane as
normal don't make a scene with your
guitar don't say hey i'm bringing a
guitar just walk straight to your seat
and assuming you're able to pre-board or
buy priority access there should be all
of the bins sitting there open uh
waiting and so just simply pop your
guitar
in a convenient bin it's worth noting at
this point that different airlines have
different size overhead bins and for
sure i've flown small planes where the
bins are barely big enough for two
carry-on bags so smaller planes might
not have enough room to carry a
full-size guitar actually in the
overhead in this case you can still try
the closet but it's really risky so look
ahead to find out which type of plane
you're flying on and you can even
sometimes find the measurements of the
overhead compartments if you want just
call the airline and they can usually
tell you so as you can tell i had a
pretty easy experience and this is
reflective of most of my time
traveling but of course you can run into
some problems so what happens for
example if you cannot pre-board or
you're in group six and you simply can't
get on early and all the overhead bins
are full and you have your precious
guitar well in this instance they will
gate check your instrument and what that
means is they will
personally give it to someone and they
will take it down to the plane and put
it down there they usually put like an
orange tag or something on it to
identify it and then when you leave the
plane it'll be waiting right there with
like strollers and wheelchairs this is
actually not terrible because it means
that it's carried down the last minute
and brought right back up at the end uh
it's still not humidity controlled down
there the temperatures are or who knows
what
uh probably not great for an instrument
and it's still kind of thrown around by
some who knows you know random guys so
obviously it's still a bit scary and i
try to go for options one or two in fact
i've never had to gate check an
instrument so that should say something
then of course another option is to
actually check your instrument so when
you show up at the very beginning to
check in you can check it just like you
would a large bag
personally i think this is the absolute
worst option what this means is
way before some labyrinth of tunnels
at checkout all the way to your plane
they put it on a conveyor belt and then
it's just dropped and dropped and turned
and dropped and then carried and thrown
again and again and again and i've seen
some videos where they simply just drop
a couple feet it looks terrible and i
think this is where uh all the bad stuff
seems to happen i do have a lot of
colleagues who have horror stories about
checking instruments and opening it at
the other end to find the whole thing is
looks looks awful now there is one more
option but it is the most expensive
option you can buy a seat for your
instrument i've done this a lot luckily
most the time i'm being flown out to
play with a company and they pay for the
seat but sometimes i'm bringing back an
instrument from europe and i have to
simply pay for it when i have bought a
seat myself it's usually just because
the instrument won't fit in the overhead
or i'm flying in europe on like a cheap
airline
like ryanair where for sure they're not
going to let you get away with anything
there is no putting in the closet the
bins are too small you simply buy a seat
but in those instances the flights are
usually a bit cheaper like i did a
flight from i think spain to the uk and
it was pretty cheap and i simply just
bought a bodysuit for it and
unfortunately having your guitar in a
seat doesn't get you an extra meal or
drink
now before we call this video an end i
have a couple other miscellaneous tips
you could use for flying the first thing
is to consider what type of case you're
using i probably wouldn't use a gig bag
like a really simple cloth bag i think
the more rigid the case the better so if
you have a hard wooden case obviously
that's the best i actually flew this
time a little risky i was using a
semi-rigid case very lightweight with
backpack straps easy to carry through
the airport much nicer for me and i was
confident i can get in the overhead but
generally if you do have to gay check it
you're going to want it to be as strong
as possible the other thing you really
must do when you fly i think is you
should
detune all the strings
all the way down and usually i do it
until they kind of don't really have a
pitch
anymore
so something like this where the string
is just totally floppy uh that's that's
good i do all the strings like that the
main point is you want to take off the
tension from the instrument because the
strings are pulling this way in the on
the bridge and if your guitar was
dropped if it had to be gate checked or
if you drop it coming out of the
overhead or whatever the impact is worse
for the instrument if there's all this
tension pulling on it usually the bridge
can rip off or the the headstock can
break here i had a friend where their
headstock broke right here in half and
they were able to get repaired but
let's not have this happen to you so
detune the strings before you fly the
other thing i did was i took extra
clothes i had socks underwear t-shirts
and i just made sure that all of the
negative space in the case was filled
you could do this with bubble wrap if
you want but for me i was actually
trying to conserve space in my carry-on
and it was great i just got to put a
bunch of clothes
packed in there and it makes it so the
guitar doesn't wiggle around and get
injured if it was to drop so this is how
i fly with an instrument i've used all
these tips many times and i've never had
an issue although i have to tell you no
matter what when you fly with an
instrument it's stressful i'm never
happy until i'm on the plane with the
instrument secure uh maybe not even
happy until i get to the destination and
open it up and tune it and see it's okay
it's a stressful thing you're you're
scared that they might turn you down
smile be calm uh be very very very
polite
and in my experience it's worked every
time so i really hope this video helped
you if you enjoyed it you could give
back very easily by subscribing to my
channel for many more guitar tips and
educational videos like this one and if
you're enjoying learning about classical
guitar and are ready to take it
seriously and learn it yourself
i have a new online classical guitar
course it's a six hour course where i
teach you everything you need to know to
get started in your first pieces
it's great because you get to learn from
the comfort of your own home you can
check it out in the link in the
description and actually this labor day
weekend it is 50 off so do get it while
you can i also wanted to quickly mention
before you go that my online music
school arpeggiato a school for all
things that go pluck is hosting a free
master class september 10th head to
arpeggiato.com the link is in the
description for free you can come on
september 10th join us on zoom and get a
really great experience learning about
guitar from one of our expert
instructors you'll also find on our
website a series of replay videos we've
done 10 master classes 10 workshops it's
all sitting there an hour and a half a
piece over 30 hours of footage just
sitting there waiting to be
seen and waiting to help you learn the
instrument so again head to the link in
the description and you'll find all that
content online waiting for you workshops
master classes and of course expert
teachers who can teach you one-on-one
via zoom these are people that i've
hired because they are wonderful
teachers and fantastic players in their
instruments so check out arpajatto.com
to learn more about that and i will see
you guys next time
[Music]
you